Speaker 1: Yesterday I told you about the
Republican congressman elect, George Santos,
who got caught lying about his employment history
and he got caught lying about his educational
history and he got caught lying that he had four
employees that were victims of the Pulse nightclub
shooting. Now, George Santos has been saying that
he is a gay Jewish man and it turns out that he
does not appear to be Jewish. I guess he's still
really gay. We don't know. But the Jewish part
seems to have also been part of his completely
made up story. LGBTQ Nation Reporting Gay, Jewish,
Republican, Congressman elect busted in another
fake claim. He's probably not Jewish either.
LGBTQ Nation writes about a New York Times piece
exploring all of the different lies that he told
about education and the other things that we
talked about. And then it goes on to say. Now
another falsehood has likely been exposed. Santos
touted his Jewish heritage to woo Orthodox Jewish
voters, but Jewish Telegraphic Agency reports
that more than likely, that is fake, too. The
outlet went back through Santos, his appearances
and claims, and concluded that, as with so much
else in his personal narrative, there is little to
suggest truth beyond his own past comments. Santos
identifies as Jewish through his mother, although
his father was Catholic. Santos has said that he
is Catholic. That's common in America for someone
to identify as ethnically Jewish and religiously
Christian. According to the outlet, both his
parents are Brazilian. His biography includes
the info that George's grandparents fled Jewish
persecution in Ukraine, settled in Belgium and
again fled persecution during World War Two. They
ultimately settled in Brazil, where his mother
was born. Sounds reasonable. Santos his mother,
Fatima, devout, older, died in New York City,
and her obituary doesn't claim Jewish heritage.
Fatima is a famous Roman Catholic appellation for
the Virgin Mary. What this means is. I've never
met a Jew named Fatima. That's essentially what
is being written here. Deval There is a Flemish
name validating his claim about Belgian heritage,
but the Flemish people are overwhelmingly
Catholic. Santos's sister and his lawyer
all refused comment. But Matt Brooks,
CEO of the Republican Jewish Coalition,
told the outlet he questioned the duplicitous
GOP congressman elect. I asked him about this he
identifies as Jewish. So this appears to be a lie
as well. Now, I don't know. It's not stolen valor,
but stolen valor is something we talk about
people who claim military service when they
were not in the military or they say, well, I
had combat in the military when they did not
see combat in the military. This isn't stolen
valor, but it's something else as applied to
the Jewish people. And many of you know that I'm
Jewish. Jewish heritage and identity and ethnicity
are really closely tied to the culture and history
of the Jewish people and the oppression of Jewish
people for 2000 years. And for a lot of Jews, it's
an important part of our identity. And so when you
see someone that is claiming this and it is made
up in this case potentially to woo Orthodox Jewish
voters, you are attempting to profit from a story
that has a lot of tragedy and it has a lot of
horrible things that affects and guides how Jewish
people feel today without actually having that in
your family history, without actually having lived
it. And the sum total of the lies that this guy
has told in any normal job would get you fired.
I mean it in normal jobs. If it was uncovered
after you were hired by H.R., that you lied about
your employment history and you lied about your
educational history, you know, the Jewish thing
is more of an. From an employment standpoint,
it's less relevant to claim that you are Jewish
when you are not. But the some totality of this in
any normal job would get you fired. And this is a
guy who I can't imagine that. I mean, he was vote
they voted for him. They voted for him maybe based
on some lies. If he had said, hey, you know what,
I actually don't really have any relevant
employment history or impressive education,
and I don't share an identity with the Orthodox
Jewish voters. And it's possible that he might
have lost. Of course, it is too late at this point
in time, but starting starting off strong, an
incredibly historic level of dishonesty from a guy
that was celebrated by many, including by people
like Glenn Greenwald. Look, it's Republicans
electing a gay congressman and blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah. Seems like he made everything
up. The last thing would be, is he actually gay?
And I couldn't care less one way or the other.
He's a liar. That's what I care about. But it
seems for now, that is the one part of his claimed
person of personal description that remains true.